Kota is with us in Dallas hi Dakota how
are you I'm good how are you better than
I deserve what's up so I was introduced
to your program when I was about 18 and
that was seven years ago since then I've
been working for that entire time and
got married a couple of years ago so my
wife and I had been saving very
aggressively towards our first home and
and next month we're actually moving out
of our apartment and we will pay cash
for our first home so we're excited
about that
it's an $80,000 condo so it's a starter
home but we're able to completely avoid
a mortgage way to go my question though
is could we borrow approximately five
thousand dollars for renovations which
would not be substantial mostly just
painting and perhaps installing some new
flooring as well as fixing up one of the
showers because basically this this
check we're about to write is going to
bring us a pretty pretty close to the
danger level on our checking account we
may only have two or three thousand
dollars after that mm-hmm and so do you
have an emergency fund we do at this
point we'd have approximately thirty
five hundred dollars in there which is
not as strong as I'd like it to be and
one of our goals in the near future is
to maybe get it up closer to six or
seven thousand just so that it can be
you know three months supply I realize
this may not be a good idea our thought
was that we could borrow from that for
about a month to make this downpayment
because we're able to save right now
about twenty five hundred a month so we
could replenish it pretty quickly mm-hmm
okay
down payment I thought you said you were
paying cash excuse me we are paying cash
I was using that term incorrectly but
we're paying cash but again it's going
to leave us with about three thousand
dollars or so in your checking money in
checking in about thirty five hundred in
your emergency fund
well the emergency fund is contained in
our checking oh oh oh you will have
$1,000 to your name that's right okay
yeah number one your emergency fund
should not be in checking it should be
set aside separately so that you don't
accidentally use it
okay that's sidebar okay so we need five
thousand dollars and you can do it at
the rate of twenty five hundred a month
right yes okay and when were you closing
approximately December 20th
good okay and when is your lease up at
the end of January
now the arrangement and the contract is
that the current owner will lease from
us for one month so that he can get his
affairs in order and find somewhere else
to live oh okay during that only out by
January 19th
okay so during that month you have
$2,500 more do you not we should know
yeah so now we're only 2,500 hours apart
right and there's a chance that we will
choose to live with the paint and live
with the current carpet but we just
haven't quite decided whether or not who
I prayed those things and we are aware
that it would perhaps be easier to do
that before actually living there oh
absolutely
definitely be easier to do it that's
what I'm trying to help you I'm trying
to figure it out with you have you
anything you could sell not really we've
got two cars a 2015 Chevy Cruze in a
2001 Corolla but those are our work
vehicles Sherman okay excuse me I said
2001 cola 2011 how much are you putting
too much are you putting into retirement
right now we've been doing 350 a month
and our and we actually have about
25,000 currently in our in our IRAs that
actually is another matter of discussion
currently because we had been planning I
would not usually spend our retirement
savings for about 24 months - totally
just to save up towards our first home
that was before this opportunity
presented itself to buy the 80,000
kondou mmm so now we're wondering should
we sew back here's what I would do and
just keep saving 350 yeah here's what I
would I would shut down everything and
try to make the goal temporarily try to
make the goal of getting in here for
cash here's so here's what I hear
listening to you an 18 year old guy
seven years ago started a plan that is
more genius than 98% of Americans
you're paying cash for an $80,000 condo
at 25 years old dude that makes you such
a rockstar and I can show you can't I
just quit that I collectively make
seventy five years you know or not I
cannot sit here emotionally and talk to
this Rockstar guy who's so incredible
and and allow him to go into debt you
did it I mean so you just got to do it
you got to find a way you've always
found a way and so we stopped retirement
we delay moving in a month instead of
moving in in the middle of January
moving in the middle of February that
gives you 2,500 2,500 you're there or
you delay the repair I don't know and
it's not gonna kill you it's not a
bankruptcy offense I mean you're not
gonna be in the stupid column no matter
what you do but just emotionally you did
it
and I can't now that you did it I can't
fathom you going into debt I can't even
digest that emotionally you're such a
rockstar you're such a stud and now
you're gonna throw a baby ruth in the
pool no ma'am don't do it you know don't
do it you know you're you made it this
close you know what I'm saying don't do
it you can do this man you've convinced
me I just I just don't know how exactly
but you're within and that's breath I
mean you're right there you're right
there and so I mean you get 2,500 of the
repairs done and you move in and you
deal with the other 2500 after you move
in or you delay moving in a month
or something else happens or I don't
know but you're right there don't give
up now you've done something nobody does
you understand that nobody pays cash for
the first hour we have any friends who
can relate to our choices I mean I think
some people are under the impression
that we're living on $10 an hour because
we live humbly and they perhaps assume
that we don't know people think you're
getting ready to pay cash for your first
house at 25 years old that makes you a
stud touchdown
now don't go 4-2 and lose the game
touchdown you're 1 you're too close man
you did it I'm so proud of you
absolutely amazing the rest of you stop
your whining after that call just stop
your whining